na wie viel Geld braucht ihr so reichen
459 Euro im Monat oder wären 502 doch
besser und werd über bereit für 300 Euro
extra jeden Tag arbeiten zu gehen oder
eher nicht der Zoff um dieses Geld das
Bürgergeld tobt seit Wochen und es geht
echt voll zur Sache wer sich so verhält
wer den Weg von Donald Trump der
Verbreitung von Fake News einschlägt wer
der Meinung ist man müsste das Land
Spalten der hat nichts mehr in der
politischen Mitte dieses Landes verloren
das ist ein Wettbewerb der Schäbigkeit
auf dem Rücken der Betroffenen Union
Verachtung vererbe oder Hetze
vorgeworfen wird macht man Ergebnisse
unmöglich es geht dabei natürlich um
Arbeitsmarktpolitik aber auch um das
Grundverständnis der Parteien und
natürlich um Wähler Stimmen mein Name
ist Jana Zimmermann und ich bin
politische Korrespondentin im
Hauptstadtstudio des ZDF am Ende dieses
Beitrags werdet ihr wissen warum die SPD
mit dem Bürgergeld ein Trauma loswerden
will und wer im Machtkampf ums
Bürgergeld gewonnen hat
[Musik]
5,4 Millionen Menschen die bisher Hartz
IV bekommen haben werden ab dem 1 Januar
2023 bürgergeld-empfänger sein
Bürgergeld klingt irgendwie super oder
nämlich so als bequeme jeder Bürger
einfach Geld stimmt aber nicht es ist
das neue Arbeitslosengeld 2 und man muss
es beantragen ich habe hier auch
irgendwo einen Antrag ja
ganz schön viel beidseitig
einfach so geht gar nichts Friedrich
Merz sagt gerne das Bürgergeld und
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen fast
dasselbe sein aber die Union hat nun am
ursprünglichen Plan drei Änderungen
durchgedrückt und hoppla jetzt sind
Grundeinkommen und Bürgergeld gar nicht
mehr dasselbe und noch viel
erstaunlicher des Bürgergeld ist gar
kein Bürgergeld mehr diese
vertrauenszeit wird komplett gestrichen
und damit ist im Grunde genommen auch
der Kern des Bürgergeldes so wie die
Koalition ist geplant hat komplett
gestrichen viele denken ja hat vier gab
es schon immer es wurde aber erst 2005
eingeführt und zwar von der SPD damals
wie heute haben die unionsgeführten
Länder im Bundesrat den ursprünglichen
Entwurf gestoppt und auf Änderungen
bestanden das war im Dezember 2003 und
ist fast genau 19 Jahre her damals hieß
der Kanzler Schröder und Angela Merkel
war echt noch ganz schön jung die Union
hat damals durchgesetzt dass man
Arbeitslosen so ziemlich jeden Job
zumuten kann die SPD war aber keineswegs
unschuldig an der miesen Stimmung gegen
Arbeitssuchende war der Höhepunkt des
neodiberalismus und SPD-Kanzler Schröder
klang wie heute Markus Söder es gibt
kein Recht in den Zeitungen war sehr
viel von Sozialschmarotzern die Rede
dabei gab es damals wirklich keine Jobs
die SPD hat für diese Reform teuer
bezahlt das ist das
Hartz-IV-Reform ist das Image der
Sozialdemokratie als einer Schutzmacht
für die kleinen Leute doch stark unter
die Räder gekommen der tolle Name
Bürgergeld soll also möglichst schnell
das Böse Hartz IV vergessen lassen man
will den Arbeitslosen nun auf Augenhöhe
begegnen so ein bisschen nach der Kunde
ist König das hat auch was damit zu tun
dass inzwischen überall händeringend
nach Arbeitskräften gesucht wird deren
Marktwert ist also gestiegen und wie das
in der Marktwirtschaft so ist wer hoch
im Kurs steht wird besser behandelt das
Bürgergeld der Ampel soll weiterhin
wohnen und Heizkosten angemessener Größe
und höher erstatten und statt bisher 449
soll es nun 522 € geben zweitens sollen
die Leute besser qualifiziert werden
außerdem sollte eine vertrauenszeit
kommen die sechs Monate lang
weitestgehend auf Sanktionen verzichtet
und eine Karenzzeit in der man Vermögen
bis 60.000 Euro und seine eventuell ein
bisschen zu große Wohnung behalten darf
[Musik]
nun aber sagt die Union das Bürgergeld
sei viel zu nah an dem was ein
Geringverdiener bekomme da gibt es ja
keinen Anreiz mehr arbeiten zu gehen
jede Menge Zahlen kursierten das ganze
ist allerdings echt kompliziert zu
berechnen denn viele Geringverdiener
können zusätzliche staatliche Hilfen wie
Wohngeld oder Kinderzuschuss beantragen
dann stehen sie immer besser da als
bürgergeld-empfänger manchmal aber sind
es eben nur ein paar hundert Euro so
dass vielleicht zum Beispiel eine
alleinerziehende findet da kümmere sie
sich doch lieber um ihre Kinder als den
ganzen Tag zu arbeiten wenn der Abstand
zwischen Bürgergeld und einem niedrig
bezahlten Job so niedrig ist ist das das
Problem des Bürgergeldes das habe ich
Wolfgang Schröder gefragt
Politikwissenschaftler an der
Universität Kassel dieser Abstand ist
aber ganz schwer her zu stellen weil wir
ein extrem hohen Niedrig Lohnsektor
haben und diese extrem hohen
Niedriglohnsektor der macht die
Abgrenzung zu den existenziellen
Leistungen schwierig wenn wir jetzt
nicht die starke Mindestlohn Anhebung
hätten dann wäre die wahrscheinlich
Möglichkeit dass es eine wirkliche klare
Grenze gibt kaum zu erreichen es gibt
einfach auch in unserem Land jede Menge
Jobs nämlich etwa jeden fünften die so
schlecht bezahlt sind dass man davon
kaum leben kann und dazu kommt das bis
zu 50% derjenigen die zu ihren schlecht
bezahlten Jobs staatliche Unterstützung
bekommen könnten diese gar nicht
beantragen weil es zu kompliziert ist
sie nicht wissen wie oder sie sich
schämen dabei sollten sich ja wohl
diejenigen schämen die solche Jobs
anbieten und alle die das Deuten SPD und
Grüne regen sich jedenfalls fürchterlich
über die Position der Union auf erstens
vermutlich weil sie selbst wissen dass
Bürgergeld und
geringverdienstgefährlich nah
beieinander liegen zweitens weil die
Union die gegen die Erhöhung des
Mindestlohnes war jetzt sagt das
Bürgergeld sei zu nah am Mindestlohn ja
dann muss der wohl noch weiterlaufen und
drittens weil sie finden die Union
Spieler Arbeitslose gegen
Geringverdiener aus vor allem aber weil
die Union Ihnen den ganzen schönen
bürgergeldplan hätte ruinieren können
oder ruiniert hat die Kalender in denen
die CDU oder CSU regiert weigerten sich
Mitte November nämlich im Bundesrat des
Gesetz zu bestätigen sie bemerkten jetzt
vor allem dass es zu wenig Sanktionen
gäbe Markus Söder etwa wir fühlen uns da
immer als Anwalt der fleißigen die
fleißigen das sind alle die denken dass
sie richtig viel arbeiten da hat er
schon mal einen großen Fanclub und so
wie die meisten Leute denken sie fahren
besser Auto als der Durchschnitt zu
denken auch sehr viele dass sie ganz
besonders fleißig sind jedenfalls
fleißiger als die meisten anderen sich
auf die Seite der fleißigen und strengen
zu stellen ist immer sehr populär die
SPD allerdings nennt das populistisch
das ist beim Bürgergeld eine
vertrauenszeit geben sollte die für
sechs Monate nur minimale Sanktionen
vorsah damit Jobcenter und
Arbeitssuchende sich aufs Arbeit suchen
konzentrieren können fand die Union
ebenfalls und zulässig vertrauensvoll
dazu sollte man wissen momentan sind es
nur drei Prozent aller
Leistungsempfänger bei denen überhaupt
Sanktionen verhängt werden und
schließlich fand die Union ist nicht gut
dass Menschen die 60.000 nur angesperrt
haben diese zwei Jahre lang behalten
dürfen und trotzdem Bürgergeld beziehen
das was die SPD die größte Sozialreform
seit 20 Jahren nennt wurde von der Union
blockiert und musste in den
Vermittlungsausschuss das ist ein
Gremium in dem traditionell Kompromisse
gefunden werden doch schon in den
Vorgesprächen tat sich eine verblüffende
Allianz auf die FDP hat wohl vergessen
dass sie schon lange nicht mehr
Koalitionspartner der CDU ist und viel
den anderen beiden Regierungsparteien
voll in den Rücken hier müssen sich auch
SPD und Grüne bewegen bewegen und ich
bin sogar der Meinung dass wir hier so
weit gehen können um auch diese
vertrauenszeit ja auch fallen lassen
können dafür bekam er vom eigentlichen
Koalitionspartner gleich auf die Mütze
beim Bürgergeld würde ich weiterhin dazu
raten nicht Dinge auf der öffentlichen
Bühne auszubreiten sich schon gar nicht
aufzuplustern die vertrauenszeit war
dann aber am nächsten Morgen wirklich
weg waren auch 12 Monate der Karenzzeit
in der Wohnung und Vermögen von
Leistungsempfängern unangetastet bleiben
und an schon Vermögen braucht man jetzt
nur noch ein Jahr lang höchstens 40.000
Euro behalten Sieg der Union auf der
ganzen Linie Pressekonferenz auf der
Fraktionsebene des Bundestages am
Dienstag den 22 November Auftritt der
Ampel trauertruppe fast ganz in schwarz
mit enthüllenden Kommentaren die FDP die
von staatlichen Leistungen ja eh wenig
hält scheint das Bürgergeld mit
unionseinwirkung noch besser zu finden
als den ursprünglichen Entwurf der
Regierung die SPD behauptet hinter den
Kulissen dass sie beim Schonvermögen
extra Hochgepokert habe damit die Union
was zu kürzen hat nach außen aber lobt
sie den Kompromiss und beschwört es sei
trotzdem eine historische Reform nur die
Grünen waren ehrlich enttäuscht Britta
Hasselmann Klang als hätte sie eine
Grabrede die vertrauenszeit sie ist
nicht mehr genau gegenüber auf der
Fraktionsebene im Bundestag der Auftritt
der Union triumphpfahl Friedrich Merz
der sich darüber wundert wie schnell die
Ampel eingeknickt sein klare und
geschlossene Haltung der Union hat
offensichtlich auch dazu geführt dass
die Koalition
relativ schnell und ich muss Ihnen auch
sagen sehr weitgehend ich will sogar
sagen zu meiner Überraschung sehr
weitgehend bereit war hier auch
entsprechende Kompromisse zu machen und
eine wusste wie immer dass es genau so
kommen würde und das alles seine
Masterplan folgt wir haben das Thema ja
auch extra auf einer Tonlage
gespielt bei der immer klar war dass es
eine Einigung zwischen Regierung und
Oppositionen in dieser Frage geben wird
kleine Anekdote am Rand bei der
Generaldebatte am Mittwoch soll es eine
Absprache gegeben haben dass weder März
noch Scholz über das Bürgergeld sprechen
März hat sich daran gehalten Scholz
nicht nicht sauber gespielt darin kann
man sehen dass er sich in der Sache als
Verlierer sieht souverän ist das nicht
aber rache ist süß ende gut alles gut
das finden weder Sozialverbände noch die
Linke die fordern 200 Euro mehr für
Bürgergeld Empfänger und eine Anhebung
des Mindestlohns auf 13 Euro in
Möglichkeit erleben wir einen Comeback
von Hartz IV ich habe es im Bundestag
Hartz 5 genannt und diese Einschätzung
bleibt kaum ein Hartz-IV-Empfänger
springt jetzt wohl vor Freude im Quadrat
weil er nun ein bürgergeld-empfänger ist
und bei der Inflation 53 Euro mehr
bekommt die Debatte hat aber doch
einiges freigelegt die Dünnhäutigkeit
der SPD die Hartz IV vergessen lassen
will und sich ärgert dass das nicht
gelingt die Tatsache dass die Union sich
nicht scheut die Ärmsten unter
Generalverdacht zu stellen um Beifall
von den nicht ganz so armen zu bekommen
vor allem aber die Abstiegsängste in der
aktuellen Krise fast drei Viertel der
Deutschen blicken momentan sorgenvoll in
die Zukunft oder haben sogar sehr große
Angst und da gibt es wohl das Bedürfnis
eine klare Grenze nach unten zu ziehen
dabei wäre es vielleicht interessant mal
in die andere Richtung zu gucken
momentan geht man davon aus dass Hartz
IV missbraucht den deutschen
Steuerzahler jedes Jahr 60 Millionen
Euro kostet das ist wahrhaftig viel Geld
aber durch Geldwäsche gehen und jedes
Jahr 100 Milliarden durch klappen ist
Steuern hinterziehen ein Ausdruck von
besonderem Arbeits Fleiß oder warum regt
sich darüber niemand auf
[Musik]
das Bürgergeld kommt aber der schöne
Name hat seinen Glanz schon vorher
verloren der Streit hat uns daran
erinnert dass wir ein noch ungewohntes
Problem haben zu wenig Arbeitskräfte
wenn die Wirtschaft aber mehr
Arbeitskräfte braucht dann braucht es
wohl auch bessere Arbeitsplätze nicht
solche bei denen man in Versuchung kommt
mit sehr wenig Geld auf dem Sofa liegen
zu bleiben wie seht ihr das ist das
Bürgergeld fair zu großzügig oder ein
Bluff was ist gerecht wenn es um die
Unterstützung von Arbeitslosen geht
schreibt es uns in die Kommentare wir
freuen uns wenn ihr unsere Beiträge
liked und den Kanal abonniert und schaut
doch mal in die Beiträge meiner
Kolleginnen